They didn't want me
to create a Zedd song.
They wanted me to create
a piece of music that
matches what this is all about.
[music playing]
My first thoughts when
the project came to me
was, finally, and
excited, because I've made
classical music in my life.
I've always wanted to be
more in the scoring world.
And the way it was
presented to me
is, it's a project
that Darren Aronofsky
is filming for Nat Geo.
And I'm a big fan, so I
was immediately interested.
So what I find really
inspirational about One
Strange Rock is that it's much
more visually stimulating,
and it keeps you
engaged with the topic,
and it was my mission to try to
match that in the audio world.
So in the series, it's a
lot about seeing things
from a different perspective.
And even if you think you
know what a certain thing is,
looking at it from a
different perspective
you learn a new side of it.
And that's the thought behind
this chord progression as well.
The first half is all one
bass note, and these chords,
this melody, that's
really haunting.
You think you've
heard it already.
But it never really opens up.
It's always this question mark
because of this pedal note.
It doesn't move.
And then after that big reveal,
you see that exact same melody,
the same chords, but with
a different bass note,
and it opens up a completely
different emotion.
The second step was obviously
recording that piano
and then adding elements to it--
cinematic moments, some
hits that really grab
your attention, building a huge
climax, and then the orchestra
is a big piece.
I asked my friend Brian Tyler
to help orchestrate this piece.
Then it goes back up.
I'm in the process
of the second half
of the songs, which is
the big climax where
the whole orchestra comes in.
And [music starts] I
really want to find a way
to add my elements
to it, that sound
like Zedd, but keep the epicness
of this choir and orchestra.
So I'm still halfway done.
[music playing]
I hope that when people
hear this piece of music
that I made for
One Strange Rock,
they will realize that
I am capable of writing
emotional music outside of
what they think I can do.
And I just hope that
people give this a chance
and really listen to it, and
listen to the intricacies
and details of the
chord progression,
and how this musical
piece changes
you when you listen to it.